[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and we have
some awesome new leaks and information
on the upcoming Marvel movie Black Widow
throughout this video I'm gonna be going
through all of the things that have
dropped on the internet today and if
it's true then the movie really sounds
like it's gonna be incredible now there
will of course be heavy spoilers here
it's the heavy spoilers channel the
heavy spoilers show yada yada yeah so
this is your last chance to back out
like always leaks like this should be
taken with a pinch of salt but this
spoils the major villain reveal and a
couple of cameos so if you don't want to
know anything and then now's your time
to turn off without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into the
breakdown okay so the new leaks were
posted to the Marvel Studios spoilers
reddit thread today and I'm just going
to be going through the post itself and
giving my thoughts on it it starts at
the beginning of the film and kind of
flashes it out from there okay so
following Captain America Civil War
Natasha Romanoff is lured back to
Budapest and reunites with a sister
Yelena bellover played by Florence Pugh
the red-room program created by
Natasha's surrogate father general Ivan
Petrovich trained them both to become
black widows the Red Room is now led by
Melina Vostok off who's been abducting
girls and trying to create a new
generation of black widows Natasha and
Yelena set out to stop her
aided by Natasha's older lover Rick
Mason played by ot [ __ ] Benelli I'm just
gonna say it now I'm gonna get
everyone's name wrong in this entire
breakdown but stick with me who's a
fixer for international spies and who
previously worked for shield Natasha and
Yelena are pursued by taskmaster and
mercenary affiliated with Vostok off who
is capable of mimicking his opponent's
fighting pants anyway to face him
Natasha and Yelena recruit their brother
quote-unquote alexei shush Kitab played
by david harbor a boisterous drunken
super soldier originally meant to be the
red Guardian the Russian counterpart to
Captain America the action scenes
include Natasha
and Yelena fighting in a run-down
apartment Natasha and Yelena fleeing on
motorcycles while taskmaster chases them
Natasha and Yelena breaking Alexio of a
gulag and is hasha infiltrating the Red
Room headquarters and fighting rustic
off in a laboratory flashbacks Chronicle
Natasha's childhood training escape and
eventual recruitment by shield the
cameos include William Hurd as secretary
Thaddeus Ross Robert Downey jr. is Tony
Stark in a deleted scene where he urges
Natasha to run and Jeremy Renner is also
rumored to appear as Hawkeye suits
include the standard suit a white
stealth suit for a snowy environment and
a reinforced combat suit the main plot
twist is that Mason is actually
taskmaster and the movie ends with
Natasha reconnecting with Steve Rogers
and Sam Wilson the movie sets up Yelena
as the next Black Widow in the MCU and
she's more morally ambiguous than
Natasha which apparently sets up a new
dynamic and that's all of the leaks okay
so lots of really exciting stuff in
there and honestly if this is true it
sounds like it's going to be the best
action movie and the MCU now some more
exciting news that was added to the
thread also said that the stunt
coordinator of the amazing skydiving
scene in Mission Impossible fallout will
be working on the film and there really
is the potential for this to be a
stellar action film hope this is the
Bourne movie of the franchise and so far
it all sounds like it's lining up to be
incredible
the time between Civil War and infinity
war is an awesome time to explore stuff
and this could really be something
special if they managed to pull it off I
am still slightly worried about
taskmaster as I don't know if the
villain is truly capable of being the
main baddie in the film but I think it's
all down to direction and hey
luckily the MCU movies don't tend to be
broken by having bad villains so I'm
sure they'll be fine either way
now the cameos sound absolutely awesome
and if we get a reunion of the
characters for this film I think it will
be great
I know endgame gave them the perfect
goodbye but it'll still be a nice
surprise now a lot of people have said
that this movie sounds desperate by
Disney and that they don't have faith in
the film because they're pulling out so
many people from the past however I do
think that they will do it well and
Natasha in some ways also needs to have
her good
by with the characters so yeah this will
be a nice closing of the book now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this and if you agree with me or if
you've got your own opinion on how the
film should be do you like the
information or not
and do you hope black widow being alive
is teased in a post-credits scene or
something at the end comment below and
let me know and if you enjoy this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my breakdown of the news that
Amy Pascal announced that Sony are
setting up the sinister six when
spider-man universe I'll link that at
the end and it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come chat to me on Twitter
then make sure you follow me at
definition whitey and if you want to
join my discord to talk about movies
comic books games TV shows anything that
make sure you click the link in the
description below we've got an awesome
community of people just like you and
it's the best way to stay up-to-date
with the channel also just want to let
you know that we're currently giving
away a free copy of spider-man far from
home on blu-ray and all you have to do
to be in with the chance of winning is
to like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the black widow leaks in the
comment section below the winner will be
chosen at random on October the 15th and
the Bureau be shipped out from the into
a bucket surprise it's the best of luck
that everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you liked hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]